[Música]
se dice que te hace el clic
cuando finalmente logras entender
comprender algo manejarlo como decimos
en argentina cuando te cae la ficha y
eso ocurre en diferentes ámbitos de
nuestra vida por ejemplo en el
aprendizaje de un idioma
cuando uno empieza a aprender un idioma
y ya logra pensar en ese nuevo idioma
quiere decir que te hizo el clic porque
ya no necesitas traducirlo en tu mente
yo recuerdo exactamente una de las veces
que se me hizo el famoso clic
trabajaba como maestra en el sur
argentino en la patagonia austral zona
costera un mar azul precioso gente muy
amable muy amigable pero muchísimo
muchísimo viento un día iba para la
escuela en bicicleta contra el viento
cuando de repente un auto que iba
adelante abrió la ventanilla y lanzó
algo lo siguiente que recuerdo es estar
al costado de esa calle intentando
sacarme de mi rostro y de mis cabellos
algo no sé que ni tampoco quise
investigar mucho pero allí me di cuenta
y allí sentí el clic en estéreo
porque cuando te hace el clic no
solamente te hace en la mente en los
pensamientos sino también en el corazón
porque puedes estar muy informado de
algunas cosas pero mientras no te
convenzas y no tomes decisiones al
respecto no se produce ese clic pero
mientras me iba sacando la basura de
otra persona de mi propia cara allí se
hizo el clic y me di cuenta
que mis acciones también producían
efectos en otros o en la naturaleza o en
mí misma
y a partir de allí me di cuenta que las
consecuencias vienen tarde o temprano de
las acciones que realizamos a veces
inmediatamente como en mi caso en la
bicicleta oa veces demoran pero siempre
los impactos se producen a partir de ese
momento me transformé en una defensora
de la naturaleza apasionada y a veces
hasta el extremo tratando de cuidar y de
hacer entender a otros que tenemos que
ser más responsables con la naturaleza
y a partir de ahí también entendí que no
todos no todos nos hace el clic en el
mismo momento que tenemos que ser
pacientes que tenemos que acompañarnos
motivarnos unos a otros
a nuestro mundo
le ha estado pasando lo mismo lo mismo
que a nosotros me refiero a los
habitantes aquellos que hemos estado
viviendo en este planeta y durante
siglos especialmente los últimos hemos
incrementado nuestras acciones no
responsables hacia los otros hacia la
naturaleza y hacer hacia los recursos
que compartimos entre todos pero en las
últimas décadas el acuerdo informes y
estudios se ha incrementado y esa idea
de que otros son los responsables yo no
a otros les toca resolver las cosas que
otros son los culpables de lo que está
ocurriendo no nosotros y nos hemos hecho
cada vez menos cargo de los impactos que
producimos en todos los ámbitos de
nuestra vida sólo un ejemplo
el 22 de agosto de este año de acuerdo a
una organización que se llama footprints
network
se terminaron ya los recursos que la
tierra puede producir anualmente me
refiero a los recursos naturales el 22
de agosto del 2020 ya se terminaron o
sea que necesitamos más de un planeta un
planeta y medio para poder llegar al
final del 2020 esto solamente es un
ejemplo de cómo hemos estado agrediendo
al planeta y entre nosotros también esas
décadas de
ignorancia de pensar que nosotros no
somos los responsables derivaron en
estos últimos tiempos en que comiencen a
detonarse algunos clics por experiencias
como la mía quizá en bicicleta gente que
ya se cansó de ver esos impactos de las
irresponsabilidades por ser testigos o
inclusive víctimas de atropellos de
injusticias o por miedo al futuro por
diversas razones
se comenzaron a sonar los clics en
diferentes lugares del mundo
y a inicios del nuevo milenio
como humanidad hemos sido invitados a
sumarnos a lo que se denominaron los
objetivos de desarrollo del milenio
son 8
no sabemos bien quiénes los propusieron
pero hablaban de reducir el hambre
incrementar la calidad de la educación
de la salud de la equidad el cuidado
ambiental de sumarnos entre todos fueron
15 años desde el 2000 al 2015 en los
cuales fuimos invitados interpelados por
estos objetivos para poder alinearnos y
hacer algo con todo eso que no veníamos
haciendo
terminado el periodo viendo los
resultados escasos
se tuvo que abrir el juego ya no eran
unos pocos los que tomaban las
decisiones de que había que hacer sino
que se invitó a cualquier habitante del
planeta para que propusiera objetivos a
través de una plataforma digital
se pudieron proponer muchos objetivos
muchas ideas de cómo debería ser nuestro
planeta como debería ser la humanidad de
ahora en más
y quedaron 17 los 17 objetivos de
desarrollo sostenible de ese como se los
llama en forma abreviada
lograron conjugar todas aquellas
propuestas que fueron llegando de a
miles a esa plataforma virtual
y estos objetivos
tienen
mucha certeza en cuanto a lo que quieren
alcanzar en lo que quieren apuntar y
podemos organizar estos 17 objetivos en
cinco dimensiones hay cinco áreas en las
cuales están enfocados estos objetivos
las personas el planeta la prosperidad
la paz y las alianzas que podemos
realizar y yo los invito a conocer estos
objetivos
hice un sondeo
y pregunte algunas personas conocidas
parientes amigos colegas estudiantes y
conocían los o veces sorprendentemente
la gran mayoría no los conoce cuando les
conté de que se trataba se entusiasmaron
inclusive adhirieron a por lo menos uno
de ellos así que cuando vos los conozcas
también te va a pasar lo mismo porque
uno no puede quedarse indiferente ante
estos objetivos fíjate por ejemplo los
cinco objetivos que apuntan directamente
a las personas tienen que ver con el fin
de la pobreza el hambre cero la salud y
el bienestar de toda la humanidad una
educación de mayor calidad esta equidad
de género donde todos tengamos las
mismas oportunidades hay otros 5
objetivos que están apuntados al planeta
en los ocho anteriores hasta el 2015 era
un solo objetivo relacionado con el
planeta pero evidentemente
la situación nos ha llevado a que
planteemos cinco objetivos la vida de
los ecosistemas terrestres la acción por
el clima una energía asequible y no
contaminante la importancia de la vida
en los océanos la vida submarina y el
agua limpia y saneamiento hay otros 5
objetivos que nos hablan acerca de la
prosperidad de cómo como humanidad
podemos incrementar nuestros recursos si
trabajamos todos juntos en la industria
en la innovación e infraestructura
ciudades y comunidades sostenibles
reducción de las desigualdades
producción y consumo responsable trabajo
decente y crecimiento económico van 15
hay uno de los objetivos que nos habla
de la paz de la necesidad de que
tengamos paz justicia e instituciones
sólidas y el último pero no menos
importante nos habla de lo importante
que es tener alianzas acuerdos para
lograr
estos objetivos cuando conocemos los o
de eses los objetivos como decíamos no
podemos quedar indiferentes y
seguramente al investigar más te invito
a que lo hagas a través de internet de
las diferentes plataformas te vas a
identificar por lo menos con uno de
ellos o te va a interpelar o te va a
desafiar quizás justo encuentres eso que
estabas buscando realizar concretar en
tu vida
y existen muchos recursos para
promocionarlos para motivarlos si
prestas atención ahora los vas a poder
identificar en medios de comunicación en
diferentes ámbitos porque se planifica
en base a los eau de ese se evalúan
gobiernos empresas tomando los como
parámetros y hay tantos recursos que por
ejemplo me causó muchas gracias que
encontré en internet una guía para los
vagos para cuidar el mundo para salvar
el mundo entonces desde tu casa vos
podés con tu dispositivo móvil ayudar a
cumplir algunos de estos a veces como
para que nos demos una idea de todo lo
que hay disponible pero el objetivo es
motivar sumar es interesante esto no
realmente nos desafía los grandes
problemas están reflejados en grandes
objetivos
todos ellos interconectados aunque los
hemos dividido en cinco dimensiones pero
son los grandes desafíos planetarios muy
interesantes muy desafiantes
para los que le creemos a dios
creemos lo que dice su palabra y lo que
expresa su voluntad basamos nuestra
educación
en formar personas para que sean útiles
a esta sociedad por eso nos parece
importantísimo necesario y honesto
hacernos cargo de los impactos que
producimos eso es la responsabilidad
social los impactos individuales los
impactos colectivos tenemos que
conocerlos y hacernos cargo y de alguna
forma que nuestras acciones reflejen
decisiones positivas y esas decisiones
positivas se producen por los clics
mirar cómo está todo conectado
los que creemos en dios
sabemos que el bienestar que le damos a
otras personas el bien que le hacemos a
otros es como si lo hiciéramos a él
mismo porque así lo dice en su palabra
en san mateo 25 nos dice en cuanto lo
hicisteis a uno de estos mis hermanos
más pequeños a mí lo hicisteis también
creemos que dios nos mandó a cuidar la
naturaleza a ser mayordomos de la
creación maravillosa desde el mismo
principio por lo tanto hemos sido
convocados a contribuir a participar a
arremangarnos para ser parte de las
soluciones y no de los problemas todos
esos problemas que están reflejados en
los eau veces nosotros podemos ayudar a
solucionarlos
pero también creemos que dios tiene otra
agenda
una agenda perfecta
incomparable y con una proyección eterna
fíjense que él nos mostró a través de su
palabra
que tiene un plan en isaías dios nos da
un indicio de su plan dios dijo
jiennense de alegría porque voy a crear
algo nuevo voy a crear un cielo nuevo y
una tierra nueva todo lo del pasado será
olvidado y nadie lo recordara más
por eso en nuestras aulas también
nosotros además de preparar a los
estudiantes para servir a la sociedad
actualmente también contribuimos a
prepararlos para que sean protagonistas
de esta agenda divina de este plan que
es insuperable pero ahora se nos
presenta un dilema que hacer actual la
agenda prestar atención hay que
enfatizar una y dejar la otra
saben que dios a través de la
inspiración de elena de white en el
libro de la educación nos da la
respuesta a este dilema
allí hay una cita muy clara
que nos dice lo siguiente la verdadera
educación significa más que la
prosecución de un determinado curso de
estudio significa más que una
preparación para la vida actual abarca
todo el ser y todo el periodo de la
existencia accesible al hombre es el
desarrollo armonioso de las facultades
físicas mentales y espirituales y
escucha bien esto prepara al estudiante
para el gozo de servir en este mundo y
para un gozo superior proporcionado por
un servicio más amplio en el mundo
venidero acá está clarísimo para el gozo
de servir en este mundo y para el gozo
de servir en el mundo venidero que dios
maravilloso que nos da esta claridad
para poder entender que podemos trabajar
en las dos agendas que no hay un
conflicto entre una y la otra
cuando conoces a dios y siempre es un
buen momento para hacerlo no importa qué
edad tengas qué condiciones tes o de qué
origen seas cuando lo conoces a él y
cuando reconoces el propósito que dios
tiene para tu vida cuando decís
para esto estoy acá ahí te hace el gran
clic
sin dejar de tener la agenda divina como
la gran meta de tu vida porque fuimos
creados con un anhelo de eternidad hay
mucho todavía para hacer en los veces en
aquellos grandes problemas que nos
plantea la humanidad no hay conflictos
porque nosotros perfectamente le creemos
a dios nos preparamos para servir a la
humanidad y podemos conocerlos o desees
colaborar con ellos y analizarlo
sabiamente y hay más vos y yo podemos
ser agentes de cambios positivos en los
diferentes ámbitos en los que nos toca
actuar en nuestra vida privada familiar
laboral comunitaria en nuestra nuestro
relacionamiento global podemos hacer de
agentes de cambio
porque vos y yo fuimos diseñados por
dios con aptitudes con intereses y con
talentos que nos hacen aptos para todo
este desafío que nos plantean los a
veces todos podemos hacer algo porque
dios nos equipo para eso marquemos
entonces una tendencia seamos esos
agentes de cambio mientras vos y yo
llevamos alivio sumamos fuerzas para
cumplir con estos objetivos planetarios
también podemos ayudar a otros para que
conozcan para que entiendan y les haga
el clic más importante que es decidir
aceptar en sus vidas la agenda más
sustentable de todos la de dios
del 2020 a la eternidad
[Música]